hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so for those who don't
know me yet let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i use technical analysis every day
to build up my scenarios and set up my
trades
so i decided to create a youtube channel
where i discussed all the different
tools and techniques that i like to use
to make money on the markets
so in today's video i want to make an
update on the bitcoin
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is the shot of
the bitcoin the crazy bitcoin and it's
not always like this
so when it is the case i'm happy to tell
you that i've been really spot on
all the way up guys since 10 000 on the
bitcoin all right since
basically october since i started my
youtube channel you can check all the
videos i did on the bitcoin i did maybe
around 10.
everything i've told you guys was a good
prediction
it was useful my levels that i gave you
before they happen
were actually efficient maybe not all of
them but 80
of them and my scenario which was
bullish always confirmed
the question you guys having right now
is what is happening
let me give you an answer so once again
the best
way to analyze the bitcoin is to use
illiot wave
theory why because it is working that is
my simple answer
you can use also the trend lines and
stuff like this
but your idiot with counting must be
good guys if your idiot wave counting is
wrong everything else you're gonna do
you're gonna have a wrong bias
and you're not gonna think the right way
so here
let me just recap quickly i'm not gonna
do my counting since it's inception
but this is actually what i've done all
right so let me just show you quickly
guys
how it looks this is the bitcoin
since inception and we are right now
just doing the fifth wave of this one
two three four five and that is going
for me around three hundred thousand but
we have time this is going to be in
two years maybe something like this
right now i zoom in a bit
so in this fifth wave that started here
that started at four thousand
three thousand we need to find
five waves and to respect each time
illiot wave rules once again guys for
those who want to know more about that
click on the link in the description of
this video you're going to receive a
free video guys where i explain
everything about the theory
that is very complex i read the book
wrote on by preston froster
and trust me i needed to read it a few
times guys
before understanding everything and in
the video i made for you guys it's like
a one hour training
i only you know sum up the most
important stuff
and of course there are more things to
say but i give you here
what you need to start doing it and it
is more than enough to actually get some
very useful information so
here one i need to find five ways
in this fifth waves so the one is pretty
obvious
the second two right now we guys are in
the third
wave and then we're gonna correct deeper
and then
go to 300 probably all right
if my campaign is correct if my counting
is wrong then we're gonna
find out but i believe it is correct but
this is gonna be a long time
right now let's zoom in on the daily so
i'm gonna analyze
this third wave and the question we're
having is the third wave complete guys
so if it is complete i need to find five
waves
so i've done it today one two three
four five so we are actually here why
this counting is correct guys because
you know each time i can find five waves
you know
in each type of move up and move down
each time the idiot wave principles are
respected
is one two three four five abc so right
now we are
in the one two third wave the one in
purple so this one guys all right
we are in this third wave that started
in september 20 at 10 000 and
the question is is the third wave
finished
my answer is yes guys i've done a video
one week ago
when i actually told you guys that we
are in
a fifth wave of this third wave and
that's
when we're gonna break out to which
pattern i'm having here
so let me just show you guys this
you know fifth waves are usually weak
ending diagonals are weak as well
it's one of the patterns of idiot
reformation and they usually form a
wedge pattern
so this is what i'm having here guys
all right we are right now so i can you
know see
one two three four five in orange the
triangle was here my fourth wave i told
you guys this many times
and here we are doing the fifth waves
guys and it's actually
finished all right so i'm going to tell
you what is going to happen
very soon okay you see this is an
ending diagonal means the force wave is
entering wave one territory
this is showing weakness this is showing
that the market
is out of steam and when we break the
wedge pattern so we broke it here at 57
000 we usually retest it and then we go
lower all right
but the reason i'm bearish until june
guys
is that my fifth wave are complete guys
i know this is a false wave
very easy to spot and i know this is an
ending diagonal so guys what's the
probability i have a beautiful triangle
as a false wave
and an ending diagonal in the fifth wave
with a wedge pattern that got broken and
we tested
and being wrong it's very low guys i'm
not wrong here
i'm not wrong here and i can tell you
that
we're gonna do something like this so
maybe we tested it one more time
is it gonna be an abc here it was an abc
my second purple wave was an abc so when
you have a zigzag in the
second wave you usually have a flat or
triangle in the false wave
so here i expect either something like
this
flat or triangle
so it can be descending ascending i
don't know yet all right
it can be a descending triangle it can
be many things guys we're just at the
beginning of the correction but we're
gonna correct
a thing for two months all right we're
gonna be bearish for the next two months
guys and we're gonna find some support
at
around 42 probably 42 000 because this
is
the highest level of my third wave i'm
not very confident in this i'm just
giving you this level randomly because
this is the
you know level that is from the most
likely to happen but we're gonna have
this rebound because
the you know purple cycle here is not
finished so we need a fifth wave
so we're gonna have this fixed wave then
so we're probably going to be bearish
until forty thousand forty two thousand
and then we're gonna have a strong
rebound
and the price action taking maybe you
know around
100 to 100 percent uh in the next six
months
and then we're gonna have a much deeper
correction
then i need to analyze what's gonna
happen all right it's too long but
i just turned the bearish guys for the
next two months on the bitcoin
but i'm bullish on the long run so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys